die minister werden mit einem eingangs
statement anfangen und dann haben sie
zeit für fragen
insgesamt müssen nach einer
dreiviertelstunde leider schluss machen
weil anschluss termine sind aber ich
glaube das kriegen wir gut hin
herr minister wird es ja wir sind jetzt
angekommen in der neuen normalität das
gilt nicht nur im hinblick auf die
tatsache dass der look down allmählich
zu ende geht und wir uns versuchen
wieder in der wirtschaftlich bessere
situation hervor zu arbeiten es gilt
auch für klassische pressekonferenzen
die in der letzten zeit so selten
geworden sind und deshalb bin ich froh
dass wir das hier wieder machen können
miteinander
natürlich unter einhaltung der
abstandsregel heute hat das
bundeskabinett getroffen eine sonde ist
in einer sondersitzung zusammengekommen
um den ersten teil des konjunkturpakets
zu beschließen das rasch wirkung
erzielen soll
es wird im bundestag noch am 29 juni und
im bundesrat beschlossen sein was wir
hier miteinander auf den weg bringen
wollen aber bevor ich zur sache komme
möchte ich ausdrücklich denjenigen
danken die in der kurzen zeit seit den
beschlüssen der koalition und auch bei
der vorbereitung so viel gearbeitet
haben den beamtinnen und beamten des
bundesministeriums der finanzen aber
auch all der anderen ministerien die in
tagelanger teilweise nachtarbeit dafür
gesorgt haben dass wir jetzt ein sehr
gutes sehr ordentlich und sehr präzise
vorbereitet das gesetz beschließen
können und was für arbeit das macht
werden sie daran ermessen können dass
das letzte der gesetze dass wir jetzt
heute beschlossen haben gestern um 1 uhr
19 auf den regierungs server gestellt
worden ist
über politik gibt es ja viele vorurteile
und meinung insbesondere auch die dass
sie oft zu langsam sei aber wir können
auch anders
das ist jedenfalls die botschaft die wir
mit dem beginn der pandemie immer wieder
versuchen zu zeigen und zu demonstrieren
indem wir schnell zügig und auch in dem
großen maßstab der erforderlich ist und
mit einer
solchen unvergleichlichen krise auch
umgehen zu können
das ziel dass wir mit diesen
entschlossenen schritten verfolgen ist
die wirtschaftliche erholung unseres
landes wieder zustande zu kriegen
arbeitsplätze zu sichern und dafür zu
sorgen dass wir nicht einen
langanhaltenden konjunkturdelle haben
sondern dass unser land fit gemacht wird
für die zukunft und genau das ist das
was mit dem konjunkturpaket verbunden
ist und auch den beschlüssen die wir
heute gefasst haben
wir wollen aus der krise raus mit voller
kraft und es bleibt dabei unsere
maßnahmen haben bums ich will etwas
sagen über die einzelheiten nicht alle
aber jedenfalls die wichtigsten die
zentrale maßnahme über die wir heute
entschieden haben ist die senkung der
mehrwertsteuer von 19 auf 16 prozent und
von sieben auf fünf prozent übrigens
verbunden mit der entscheidung dass die
damit verbundenen mindereinnahmen
ausschließlich beim bund anfallen damit
wir das einvernehmen mit den ländern und
gemeinden schnell herstellen können und
die auch weiter die kraft haben um jetzt
zu investieren und dafür zu sorgen dass
es auch vor ort ordentlich und schnell
zugeht was zu investieren ist also eine
senkung der mehrwertsteuer
die kommt schnell und das ist auch genau
das richtige wenn wir jetzt eine lange
vorlaufzeit hätten dann würden
vielleicht die ein oder anderen die sich
jetzt auch zu wort melden sagen was für
eine schwierige situation das wäre denn
tatsächlich würden dann ja alle warten
auf den tag wurde es mit der
mehrwertsteuersenkung endlich losgeht
und wir hätten eine längere
kaufzurückhaltung das wird jetzt nicht
kommen es geht gleich los am ersten
siebten und es geht ordentlich los sind
es ist eine grosse senkung und im
übrigen ist es so dass wir das befristet
haben darüber sind wir insbesondere der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und ich uns
völlig einig dass es keinen sinn macht
eine solche maßnahme unbefristet oder
auf sehr lange zeit zu organisieren denn
wir wollen ja eines erreichen was für
die wiederbelebung unserer
das wirtschaft ganz zentral ist dass
sich nämlich alle die ein bisschen
unsicher sind darüber wie es weitergeht
jetzt an sportfive achsen und mut fassen
oder zumindest zuversicht und sagen ich
glaube ich nutze jetzt diese gelegenheit
wenn alle aufeinander warten wenn immer
die anderen als erste was machen sollen
dann wird das mit einem
konjunkturaufschwung nichts werden
aber wenn wir uns gemeinsam
gewissermaßen gibt es bei dieser
gelegenheit dazu verabreden dass wir
darauf setzen dass die wirtschaft wieder
wächst dann glaube ich kann es uns auch
gelingen diesen aufschwung den wir so
dringend brauchen zustande zu bringen
das zweite was ganz zentrales ist
natürlich dass wir die familien stärken
wollen und der kinderbonus der in zwei
tranchen gezahlt wird das ist ein ganz
ganz großer schritt da geht es um
milliarden für familien und für kinder
in diesem land das ist sowieso gut und
ich will das auch ausdrücklich sagen
sowieso gut weil ja gerade die familien
eine ganz besonders schwere
herausforderung zu bewältigen hatten und
haben mit den geschlossenen krippen und
kitas mit den schulen den ich den ganzen
betrieb aufgenommen haben
daher gibt es eine solche entlastung
zustande zu bringen ist gut für die
konjunktur darum geht es uns hier aber
es ist auch gut als zeichen für die
familien und im übrigen ist das ganze
was wir dann nächste woche beschließen
werden mit dem konjunkturpaket ja auch
verbunden mit konkreten investitionen in
krippen und kitas in ganztagsangebote an
schulen und die qualitätsverbesserung
die dazu notwendig sind das greift da
ineinander und deshalb finde ich es sehr
gut dass wir diesen kinderbonus jetzt
hier auf den weg bringen können und man
merkt es ja überall es geht so
allmählich wieder los und ich bin ganz
sicher dass kindergärten und schulen
bald wieder den normalbetrieb aufnehmen
werden spätestens zum beginn des
nächsten schuljahres und dann glaube ich
kann das zusammen mit dem kinderbonus
auch eine gute sache sein für die
familien in diesem land an die wir immer
denken müssen und die für die zukunft
unseres landes von so großer bedeutung
sei
wir unterstützen auch alleinerziehende
indem wir dafür sorge tragen dass der
die pauschale die sie zur stützung ihrer
schweren herausforderung haben noch
einmal ganz massiv angehoben wird in
diesem und dem nächsten jahr
und was dann auch dazu gehört als
dritter großer punkt ist dass wir dem
unternehmen in deutschland helfen
es gibt ja bestimmte maßnahmen die so
immer gefordert werden bei denen es aber
wichtig ist dass man sie zum richtigen
zeitpunkt einsetzt eine dieser maßnahmen
ist die abschreibungen
unternehmen können investitionen die
getätigt haben abschreiben das gehört
zum normalen geschäft das verfolgt
normalerweise linear
man kann das beschleunigen was die
liquidität der unternehmen erhöht indem
man eine degressive abschreibung
wirklich macht das tun wir jetzt
mir war immer wichtig dass wir das nicht
außerhalb einer krise sondern in der
krise tun weil auch dort geht es ja
darum dass wir die unternehmen davon
überzeugen dass sie nicht abwarten ob es
wohl bald besser wird sondern dass sie
investieren jetzt in diesem und dem
nächsten jahr deshalb ist diese
degressive afa auch befristet sie ist
für dieses und das nächste jahr gemacht
damit jeder der sagt okay die lage ist
schwierig ich würde gerne investieren
aber vielleicht warte ich noch ein
bisschen sagt aber die gelegenheit es zu
tun ist jetzt besonders günstig und das
ist die zielsetzung die wir mit dieser
maßnahme verbinden
darum haben wir die auf den weg gebracht
darum ist sie auch so ausgestaltet und
vielleicht als hinweis an die diskussion
wir haben jetzt die konsumanreize da
geht es um tüchern
um urlaubsreisen um fahrräder und um
autos selbstverständlich das hilft den
unternehmen die all diese
dienstleistungen güter verkaufen wollen
aber es ist ja mit der alpha und der
abschreibungsmöglichkeit die wir jetzt
hier damit verbinden auch so dass wer
sich zum beispiel jetzt neue lkw s kauft
wer sich neue dienstwagen kauft davon
gebrauch machen kann dass diese
abschreibung jetzt dieser situation auch
tatsächlich greift wir haben diese
verbesserung für die unternehmen
verbunden mit einer regelung zum verlust
rück trag- und das ist vielleicht etwas
das zu den besonderheiten unseres
handelns in dieser krise gehört wenn man
als es klar wenn die wirtschaft läuft
gehen auch die steuereinnahmen zurück
aber in der realität ist es oft so dass
sich das erst zeitversetzt zeichnen die
steuererklärung gemacht werden wenn das
nächste jahr kommt so dass der
staatshaushalte bei bund und ländern und
gemeinden oft erst mit zeitlicher
verzögerung diese reduzierung der
wirtschaftsleistung abbilden kann
für die unternehmen die jetzt bedrängt
sind ist das natürlich eine ganz
schwierige situation
und darum haben wir schon mit den ersten
maßnahmen die wir im rahmen unserer
stützungsmaßnahmen beim ausbruch der
pandemie auf den weg gebracht haben zur
stabilisierung der wirtschaft viele
viele steuerliche erleichterungen
verbunden wären unter gesetzlich noch
viele weitere gemacht die dafür sorgen
sollen dass die unternehmen jetzt sofort
liquidität haben und praktisch der
steuer einnahmeverlust nicht in ein zwei
und drei jahren eintritt sondern jetzt
in diesem jahr und umgekehrt dafür
natürlich so oft dass die unternehmen
jetzt mehr liquidität und geld haben
allein der verlust rückschlag den wir
schon zwischendurch unter gesetzlich auf
den weg gebracht hatten hat über vier
milliarden euro liquidität gebracht der
den wir jetzt noch mal dazu bringen ist
nochmal soviel liquiditäts gewinn für
die unternehmen und zusammen mit all den
anderen maßnahmen die wir auf den weg
bringen glaube ich wird es dazu helfen
dass uns unternehmen gut durch diese
situation gekommen
können was wir auch noch machen
dazu wird der kollege altmaier sehr viel
genau sagen ist dass wir die soforthilfe
jetzt als überbrückungshilfe
weiterentwickeln weil wir natürlich
wollen dass jetzt nachdem wir erst mal
zumindest den meisten irgendwie über die
erste zeit mit der soforthilfe geholfen
haben sie jetzt angesichts der
fortbestehenden umsatzrückgänge trotzdem
auch noch die nächsten monate überleben
und dann dabei sind wenn die wirtschaft
in deutschland wieder wächst das
betrifft viele viele branchen für die
das notwendig ist
gemeinnützige unternehmen übrigens auch
das geht und hotels und gaststätten und
kneipen und bars clubs reisebüros die es
besonders schwierig haben und für die
besondere regelungen machen oder die
schausteller zum beispiel das alles ist
wichtig weil es zusammen passt übrigens
auch mit den maßnahmen um die es dann
nächste woche geht wenn wir unser
nachtragshaushalt beschließen und viele
gesetze die damit verbunden sind da zum
beispiel werden wir dann auch was tun
für kunst und kultur eine ganz ganz
wichtige branche die ganz besonders viel
zu leiden hat aber für die art und weise
wie wir uns selber verstehen und wie wir
die welt betrachten von allergrößter
bedeutung ist die korona pandemie ist
noch lange nicht überstanden aber wir
sind ziemlich zum richtigen zeitpunkt
dabei für den wiederaufschwung zu sorgen
und wir tun das nicht nur in diesem land
dass es mir wichtig wir tun es auch für
europa weil wir wissen dass gerade
unsere volkswirtschaft ohne ein besseres
wirtschaftliches umfeld in europa auch
nicht gut vorankommen kann
und insofern greift ein rad in das
andere schüler ja vielen dank meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lieber
kollege olaf scholz ich schließe mich
den dankesworten an unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter an
auch im bundeswirtschaftsministerium
aber auch in allen behörden die
mitgeholfen haben in den ländern bei den
verbänden den kammern der wirtschaft des
mittelstandes der handwerker sie alle
haben mitgeholfen dass wir nicht nur
schnell in der krise reagieren konnten
sondern dass wir alles in allem auch auf
hohem qualitativen niveau und sehr zügig
den menschen die hilfe vor ort in die
betriebe in die unternehmen gebracht
haben auf die sie dringend angewiesen
sind
dieses programm was wir heute in einem
großen ersten schritt im kabinett
beschlossen haben ist der richtige
schritt in die richtige richtung zur
rechten zeit
es ist ein dankeschön an millionen von
familien mit kindern die in dieser krise
besonders viel durchmachen mussten und
die mit ihrer disziplin und mit ihrer
bereitschaft anzupacken
dazu beigetragen haben dass wir als
gesellschaft und wirtschaft die
herausforderungen meistern konnten das
ist ein zeichen der solidarität an
diejenigen unternehmen und
mittelständler die nach wie vor in
bedrängnis und not sind weil der shutter
und zwar gelockert wird weil es wie
kollege scholz sagt wieder losgeht in
vielen bereichen aber die umsätze in
vielen bereichen noch unterhalb der
kosten liegen weil die kunden noch nicht
zurückgekommen sind und weil es zweifel
gibt ob denn die positiven anzeichen
anhalten werden deshalb helfen wir
diesen unternehmen und es ist ein
zeichen der hoffnung und der zuversicht
für alle unternehmen im land für
millionen von selbständigen und
millionen von arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern dass wir für die stärke
der wirtschaft in deutschland für
unseren lebensstandard für unsere
umweltstandards unsere soziale
sicherheit unsere verkehrsinfrastruktur
in unsere bildungspolitik kämpfen wollen
und das wir erreichen wollen dass die
wirtschaft unseres landes auch künftig
weltweit zu den wettbewerbsfähigsten und
zu den erfolgreichsten gehört mit dem
kraftpaket das wir geschnürt haben in
der größenordnung von 130 milliarden
euro
und wir schaffen dass die talsohle der
konjunkturellen entwicklung in der
zweiten jahreshälfte
dürfte durchschritten wird wir wollen
erreichen auch wenn zur wahrheit dazu
gehört dass wir in vielen einzelfragen
abhängig sind von entwicklungen der
weltwirtschaft vom umgang mit der
pandemie vor den infektionszahlen in den
usa in südamerika in afrika von dem
anspringen der wirtschaft in china und
in japan
aber selbst wenn man das alles
unterstellt können wir einen beitrag
dazu leisten dass deutschland als
konjunkturlokomotive seinen beitrag
leistet in europa und in der
weltwirtschaft dass wir aus der bislang
größten krise an die sich lebenden
menschen zurück erinnern können was
wirtschaftspolitik angeht
am ende gestärkt hervorgehen das was wir
vereinbart haben sowohl im steuerlichen
teil wie auch im hinblick auf die
soforthilfen die wir fortsetzen und
verbessern wollen haben wir in großer
übereinstimmung zwischen unseren beiden
häusern und zwischen unseren beiden
ministern getan
wir sind überzeugt dass die
geschlossenheit der bundesregierung und
die geschlossenheit der politischen
parteien eine wesentliche voraussetzung
dafür ist dass unsere pakete ihre
wirksamkeit entfalten können und lieber
olaf du hast ja einen historischen satz
geprägt in der letzten woche und ich
kann das nur unterstreichen und
ankündigen wir sind bereit auch in
zukunft mit den unternehmen mit der
wirtschaft mit denen die im öffentlichen
dienst verantwortung tragen gemeinsam so
eng zusammenzuarbeiten dass wir
sicherstellen können dass aus dem
erforderlichen booms nicht versehentlich
einen bums wird wo die dynamik verpufft
bevor sie wirksam geworden ist wir
können dies schaffen und deshalb setzen
wir darauf dass wir zunächst ein
stabilitätsanker im sturm sind und dass
wir anschließend die segel wieder mit
vollem kurs voraus werfen können dazu
gehört dass der mittelstands motor
wieder anspringen muss die
mittelständischen unternehmen mit über
drei millionen einheiten vom solo
selbstständigen bis zum mittelständler
mit mehreren hundert beschäftigten sind
das rückgrat unserer wirtschaft
ihnen haben wir sehr viel zu verdanken
deshalb wollen wir verhindern dass sie
unverschuldet in not geraten das breite
wellen entstehen dass viele aufgeben
müssen weil die kosten die anfallen die
fix sind nicht erwirtschaftet werden
können durch die umsätze die gesunken
sind
die größte einzelmaßnahme im
konjunkturpaket besteht darin dass wir
25 milliarden euro zur verfügung stellen
um in den monaten juni juli und august
diesen mittelständlern zuschüsse zu
ihren fixen kosten zu geben
wir machen das nicht mit der gießkanne
sondern zielgerichtet wir wollen denen
helfen die es immer noch brauchen wir
wollen dafür sorgen dass sie nicht durch
mieten durch leasing kosten durch die
rückzahlung von provisionen und vieles
andere in bedrängnis geraten und am ende
aufgeben
deshalb haben wir vorgesehen dass diese
unternehmen für drei monate bis zu
150.000 euro geltend machen können indem
sie entsprechende kosten nachweisen die
wir zwar nicht zu 100 prozent ersetzen
aber doch so dass die
fortführungsperspektive der unternehmen
gesichert ist wir stehen nach dem
historischen einbruch bei
industrieproduktion und exporte
notwendigkeit die überlebensfähigkeit
und die durchhaltefähigkeit unserer
vitalen wirtschaft und industrie
strukturen zu sichern damit das licht am
ende des tunnels erreicht werden kann
und damit wir ende 2022 unsere
traditionelle wirtschaftliche stärke
wieder erreicht haben werden das ist
unser ziel
diese überbrückungshilfen auf die wir
uns heute verständigt haben werden
unbürokratisch aber sehr zielgerichtet
durchgeführt werden steuerberater und
wirtschaftsprüfer in den prozess der
vergabe und der kostenermittlung mit
einschalten damit ist sichergestellt
dass die betrügereien und falsche
angaben so weit wie möglich unter
bleiben werden
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass dieses
geld gemeinsam mit den ländern in den
nächsten tagen bereits die programme so
geregelt werden
spätestens anfang juli die ersten
auszahlungen aus diesen programmen
möglich sind ich bin ausgesprochen
dankbar
dem kollegen urlaub scholz und der
bundesregierung insgesamt
das ist möglich war im bereich des
steuerrechts und der steuerpolitik die
grundlagen zu legen für eine
substanzielle welle von neuen
investitionen mit der degressiven afa
mit dem verlust rücktritt mit einigen
anderen maßnahmen die olaf scholz
bereits aufgezählten erwähnt hat wird es
möglich sein nicht nur den unternehmen
die in not sind und betroffen sind
sondern allen unternehmen einen anreiz
zu geben jetzt zu investieren jetzt im
maschinenpark zu erneuern
jetzt in neue digitale investitionen
geld zustecken jetzt dafür zu sorgen
dass die wettbewerbsfähigkeit ihrer
unternehmen gestärkt wird
die degressive afa ist quer durch alle
verbände und organisationen begrüßt
worden sowie das konjunkturpaket
insgesamt und sie wird dazu beitragen
dass wir im industriellen herz unserer
wirtschaft beim maschinenbau bei der
kraftfahrzeugindustrie beim fahrzeugbau
insgesamt einen wichtigen einen
wichtigen lückenschluss ermöglichen
können dass nämlich eine inlands und
auslandsnachfrage die gerade bei
privaten stark zurückgegangen ist zu
einem teil kompensiert werden kann durch
eine größere nachfrage nach
investitionsgütern und im zusammenspiel
aller maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben
setzen wir so einen wichtigen anreiz
jetzt die ärmel hochzukrempeln einen
wichtigen anreiz jetzt zu investieren
aber auch jetzt zu investieren in
höherwertige langlebige konsumgüter in
mehr nachhaltigkeit und in mehr
klimaschutz
wir sind uns beide einig dass dies jetzt
ein großer wurf und dass es darauf
ankommt diesen wurf mit allen
beteiligten zu möglichst hohen
prozentzahlen umzusetzen und zu
verwirklichen
wir wollen nicht über das spekulieren
was hätte sein können und hätte es sein
sollen
wir wollen erreichen dass das was wir
gemeinsam beschlossen haben und was auch
international auf ein ausgesprochen
positives echo gestoßen ist möglichst
vollständig möglichst zügig und
möglichst zusammenhängend umgesetzt und
durchgeführt werden kann
wir werden in der nächsten woche
wichtige entscheidungen treffen für
zukunftstechnologien mehr als dem
wirtschaftsminister ist es wichtig dass
wir die entscheidungen zur hilfe jetzt
für die in not befindlichen und
bedrängten verbinden mit einem klaren
signal für die zukunftsfähigkeit unserer
volkswirtschaft
deshalb haben wir gemeinsam die
nationale wasserstoff strategie
beschlossen
deshalb haben wir in der vergangenen
woche gemeinsam mit frankreich den
startschuss gegeben für das größte
digital project der letzten jahrzehnte
in deutschland und europa das projekt
garics dem sie inzwischen über 300
unternehmen angeschlossen haben und das
ermöglichen kann dass wir schritt fassen
in einem bereich nämlich der
datenspeicherung und -verarbeitung den
wir fast schon verloren hatten und
deshalb sorgen wir dafür dass wir ganz
generell in den bereichen der
digitalisierung der künstlichen
intelligenz vorankommen und der letzte
punkt den ich nicht als
wirtschaftsminister sondern als mitglied
des deutschen bundestages als bürger
dieses landes ansprechen möchte ich bin
etwas bedrückten etwas besorgt wenn ich
sehe wie viele familien wie viele
unternehmen darüber klagen dass trotz
all der vielen gelder die die
finanzminister schäuble und scholz die
bundesregierung die zuständige minister
in den letzten jahren bereitgestellt
haben für digitale bildung und für
verbesserte ausstattung von schulen noch
nicht dazu geführt haben dass wir in
diesen bereichen beispielgebend sind für
andere länder in europa noch nicht dazu
geführt haben dass wir sicherstellen
können dass die möglichkeiten dieser
neuen technologie genutzt werden können
für die bildung unserer kinder und für
das wiederhochfahren unserer wirtschaft
und deshalb müssen wir das ist keine
frage von milliarden oder millionen
es ist eine frage unserer
entschlossenheit in den nächsten monaten
darüber diskutieren wie wir erreichen
können dass nicht nur alle über einen
laptop und über die richtigen internet
anschlüsse verfügen sondern das über den
richtigen umgang mit daten über die
richtigen umgang mit social media
diskutiert und unterrichtet wird das wir
erreichen können dass wir beim nächsten
mal das was wir jetzt in der krise
gelernt haben direkt auch wieder
anwenden können
wir haben gesehen dass
entbürokratisierung möglich war das ist
nicht allen kolleginnen und kollegen in
der bundesregierung gleichermaßen leicht
gefallen weil es auch bedenken gab und
manche durchaus zu recht aber wir haben
gesehen dass wir vieles schaffen können
dass wir verfahren verkürzen können
und das soll uns ein anschub dafür sein
dass wir zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
dann auch überbürokratisierung über
fitness reden können für heute ist es so
dass wir einen wichtigen ersten schritt
gesetzt haben dem in der nächsten woche
mit den haushaltspolitischen beschlüssen
komplettieren und vervollständigen
werden und damit als eines der ersten
länder auch in europa zeigen dass wir
mut zur zukunft haben und dass wir
optimistisch sind dass uns dieser
wiederaufstieg gelingen könnte vielen
dank vielen dank der minister sprach von
der neuen normalität es ist die erste
pressekonferenz hier im
finanzministerium unter den corona
bedingungen deshalb haben wir einige
neuerungen
wir haben zwei saalmikrofon einmal links
einmal rechts da müssten bitte die
fragen gestellt werden und bitte das
mikrofon nicht anfassen sie wissen
weshalb ich habe nacheinander bereits
sieben wortmeldungen vielleicht kann der
avendi eine frage gestellt wird der
nächste sich schon langsam unter
einhaltung der abstandsregeln dann
richtung mikrofon begeben und außerdem
ist der kollege matt rostowski aus der
pressestelle
anwesend er ist nicht dafür da die
minister mit möglichst freundlichen
fragen zu bedienen sondern es gibt auch
die möglichkeit über e-mail fragen hier
rein zu bringen also nicht dass sie sich
wundern dass wir inzwischen auch ihren
job schon irgendwie verstaatlicht haben
andreas rinke reuters wäre der erste und
birgit marschall von der rheinischen
post folgt danach
klein ich hätte ganz gerne gefragt herr
scholz wie groß ihre sorge von der
zweiten welle ist das ist ja das was die
finanzmärkte heute und gestern bisschen
beunruhigt sie haben selber gesagt die
pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei also
müssen wir fürchten dass noch mehr kommt
und harald meyer ich hätte ganz gerne
gewußt angesichts der schlechteren
konjunktur prognosen die auch einige
institute und experten auch für
deutschland gemacht haben sehen sie eine
notwendigkeit dass deutschland die
bundesregierung ihre konjunkturprognosen
für 2020 und 20 21 noch mal korrigiert
da können schönen dank für die frage wir
leben mit dem virus das ist das was ich
immer als neue normalität beschreiben
das wird sich erst ändern wenn wir
ausreichend meditative therapien und
wenn wir an dem stoff haben und solange
das nicht der fall ist müssen wir unser
leben so organisieren dass wir
verhindern dass es zum beispiel zu einer
zweiten welle kommt das werden wir nicht
alles allein in unserer hand haben aber
wir haben viel in unserer hand und das
was wir selber bewerkstelligen können
ist mittlerweile deutschland auf den weg
gebracht es gibt überall regeln die man
beachten muss im öffentlichen raum in
den schulen in den kitas in den
gaststätten beim einkaufen wir haben die
masken pflicht wir haben dafür sorge
getragen dass der öffentliche
gesundheitssystem ist massiv ausgebaut
wurde und wird sie können sich zum
beispiel im konjunkturprogramm anschauen
dass es dort ein milliarden teures
versprechen des bundes gibt den ländern
und gemeinden dabei zu helfen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
auszubauen
jeder
einstellung die im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst in deutschland erfolgt
bis zum ende des jahres 2021 führt dazu
dass wir für fünf jahre diese
zusätzlichen personalkosten übernehmen
denn wir wissen ganz genau dass für die
verhinderung einer zweiten welle wichtig
ist dass wir sofort erkennen dass
irgendwo sich mehrere leute infiziert
haben nachverfolgen das nachverfolgen
und verhindern dass es zu einer
grösseren ausbeutung kommt und weil wir
das erkannt haben als notwendige
maßnahme zur zum umgang mit der pandemie
glaube ich ist die chance sehr sehr groß
dass wir daran vorbeikommen dass uns
diese große problematik erreicht das ist
eine naturkatastrophe das weiß jeder und
das kann sich auch jeder vorstellen dass
die so mächtig ist dass wir nur dass
mögliche machen können aber dass wir das
jedenfalls tun das ist unser ganzer
ehrgeiz und mit den von mir
beschriebenen maßnahmen sind wir auf dem
weg dazu zählt übrigens auch dass wir
uns vorbereitet haben indem wir lauter
materialien eingekauft haben und weiter
einkaufen die man braucht um auch
größere herausforderung bewältigen zu
können wenn es um gesundheitliche
maßnahmen geht
und auch das ist dem konjunkturpaket
drin dass wir entsprechend lagerstätten
einrichten die wir dann nutzen können
und es gehört dazu dass wir demnächst
die tracing haben werden alles zusammen
und noch viel mehr dass sich hier
beschrieben schreiben diese soll dazu
führen dass wir gut durch diese zeit
kommen dass der wiederaufschwung jetzt
möglich ist und dass wir das
menschenmögliche getan haben um eine
zweite welle zu verhindern und da darf
man dann doch auch darauf setzen dass
das menschenmögliche hoffentlich genug
ist ja und so konjunkturprognose
herringen 1
wir haben im augenblick keinen anlass
sie zu korrigieren als wir die
frühjahrsprognose der bundesregierung
übrigens ressort abgestimmt auf den weg
gebracht haben da galten wir vielen als
pessimistischer als die meisten anderen
institute wir hatten damals für das
laufende jahr einen einbruch von
6,3 prozent vorhergesagt es gab vorher
eine gemeinschaftsdiagnose der
forschungsinstitute die wesentlich
günstiger war um fast 2 jetzt haben wir
einzelne institute
die einige zehntel prozentpunkte in die
andere richtung gehen andere die immer
noch optimistischer sind als die
bundesregierung ist wahr ich glaube wir
haben mit dem instrumentarium was wir
haben eine sehr verantwortliche und
belastbare aussage getroffen im übrigen
kann niemand angesichts der volatilität
dieser pandemie angesichts der
ungewissheiten über die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung in wichtigen partnerländern
deutschlands voraus sagen ob sich die
konjunktur um ein oder zwei zehntel in
die eine oder andere richtung bewegen
wird und deshalb sollten wir auch nicht
den ehrgeiz haben alle 14 tage unsere
voraussagen zu korrigieren
wir werden ihnen im herbst wie jedes
jahr die herbstprognose der
bundesregierung vorlegen und sie können
davon ausgehen dass sie dann eine
umfassende einschätzung der
wirtschaftlichen situation aufgrund von
fakten und nicht nur aufgrund von
vermutungen erhalten werden das nächste
ist birgit marschall und dann ist es
glaube ich susanne landwehr von der
fertig habe auch zwei fragen eine an die
beiden minister was macht sie so
optimistisch dass die
mehrwertsteuersenkung in preissenkungen
münden wird also ich persönlich meine
eigene empirische erfahrungen ist die
viele leute haben jetzt schon die preise
erhöht im vorfeld dieser
mehrwertsteuersenkung und meine zweite
frage ist es gibt eine berichterstattung
herr scholz dass das der zweite
nachtragshaushalt ungefähr 50 milliarden
umfassen würde
stimmt das ungefähr und werden sie dafür
dann auch noch mal die schuldenbremse
noch mal aussetzen müssen
zunächst mal ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
dass es zur preissenkung kommt und ich
sehe auch überall schon erörterung zb
was autos betrifft wie viel das billiger
wird durch die mehrwertsteuersenkung was
dennoch unsere elektromobilitäts prämien
und die prämien für hybride ausmachen
wie man sich das dann
alles zusammenrechnen kann und was jetzt
ein super deal ist und deshalb habe ich
das ganz feste gefühl dass das auch
tatsächlich so stattfinden wird und dass
es überall preissenkung geben wird den
rest müssen die verbrauchern verbraucher
die verbraucherschutzorganisation die
regierung und die journalistin und
journalisten bewirkt man ich bin ganz
sicher dass wir uns das auch gelingen
wird dass wir das hinbekommen
man muss ja auch mal eins sagen man kann
ja an allem herum lagen
man kann sowieso auf der welt zu denen
zählen die in der ecke sitzen und sagen
es wird definitiv alles schlecht
ausgehen aber ehrlicherweise kann man
kein land regieren wenn man so eine
haltung hat und deshalb glaube ich dass
wir uns jetzt immer mehr auf uns selber
besinnen sollten unsere kraft zusammen
sammeln und jetzt die möglichkeiten die
wir haben auch nutzen
wir werden ein nachtragshaushalt machen
das ist klar
wir werden damit natürlich noch mal über
die grenzen hinweg gehen wird die wir
schon hin weg gegangen sind was jetzt
die schuldenregel des grundgesetzes
betrifft und die ausnahmeregelung erneut
in anspruch nehmen müssen für die
zusätzlichen beträge
wir rechnen was wir brauchen sie kennen
die zahlen für das was für 2020 und 21
aus dem konjunkturpaket erwächst sie
wissen dass wir aus dem letzten
kreditermächtigung des bundestages noch
kraftreserven haben die wir auch
einsetzen werden und dann werden wir
natürlich überlegen wie wir das über die
jahre geschickt machen also wir treffen
jetzt im augenblick auch stündlich
entscheidung darüber ob wir bestimmte
sachen die jetzt mehr mit dem thema
transformationen das zu tun und wie geht
es für die zukunft weiter wie sorgen wir
dafür dass wir vorne an sind bei
erneuerbaren energien bei
digitalisierung bei
wasserstoffwirtschaft und so weiter bei
dem
ausbau der schulen bei der den
möglichkeiten die damit verbunden sind
wie können wir das was auch über 20 und
21 hinausgeht vernünftig aufteilen auf
die verschiedenen haushaltsbeschlüsse
deshalb bewegt sich das noch ein
bisschen und mit aussagen zur höhe des
nachtragshaushaltes ist das
bundesministerium der finanzen jahr
berufsbedingt knauserig und dabei
bleiben auch ja ich teile die auffassung
meines kollegen zum thema wirkung der
mehrwertsteuer maßnahme wir haben ja
auch volkswirtschaftlich immer wieder
die erkenntnis gemacht dass
preiserhöhungen meistens dann
stattfinden wenn sie am markt
durchsetzbar sind
das heißt wenn sie auf eine große und
steigende nachfrage treffen
wir wollen ja mit unseren maßnahmen auch
erreichen dass in den bereichen wo die
nachfrage eingebrochen ist wo sie
besonders schwach ist die nachfrage
wieder in gang kommt und mensch
unternehmerinnen und einzelhandel und
konsumentinnen und konsumenten am mund
hat werden bestimmte investitionen
vorzuziehen
deshalb bin ich überzeugt dass in diesen
bereichen wohl die nachfrage notleidend
ist
viele auch sich ganz kreative gedanken
machen können werden wie sie die
mehrwertsteuersenkung und die liquidität
die wir damit in den markt geben nutzen
werden um mit eigenen angeboten sogar
die attraktivität von käufen zu erhöhen
es hat ja gibt ja viele die die
vaterschaft für diese idee der
mehrwertsteuersenkung für sich
reklamieren ich habe das nie gemacht
aber ich stehe voll und ganz hinter der
beschlossenen maßnahme weil ich glaube
dass es eine möglichkeit ist dass dieses
konjunkturpaket möglichst vielen
menschen auch tatsächlich zugute kommt
und weil ich der auffassung bin dass es
gerade dort wo es um nachhaltige umwelt
klimafreundliche lang wird ledige
konsumgüter geht die einen bestimmten
preis haben und die man nicht jeden tag
und ich jede woche kauft dass es gerade
dort zu einer segensreichen wirkungen
kommen wird so wir haben
die wortmeldungen und da die auf fragen
sehr ausführlich die antworten sehr
knapp sind muss ich jetzt leider dann
die rednerliste schließen da müssen wir
halbwegs in der zeit bleiben als
nächstes frau landwehr und dann habe ich
laut weber von in tv-shows halt mal die
einfuhrumsatzsteuer soll reformiert
werden sie haben sich jetzt dafür
entschieden die erhebung aufzuschieben
aber nicht das berechnungsmodell
einzuführen können sie sagen warum sie
nicht den ganzen schritt gegangen sind
dass das eine das zweite im
konjunkturprogramm gibt es ein
austauschprogramm für schwere
nutzfahrzeuge also unternehmen können
ihre älteren erneuerer austauschen
bekommen da eine förderung und der
finanzbedarf war da noch nicht angegeben
können sie sagen wie hoch die kosten
sein werden und wo das geld herkommen
soll
wir haben eine lange beratung über die
richtige organisation der
einfuhrumsatzsteuer gehabt in den
letzten zwei jahren
sie wissen vielleicht dass ich schon
bevor ich bundesminister der finanzen
war fest davon überzeugt war dass das
reformiert werden muss weil wir einen
großen wettbewerbsnachteil mit anderen
ländern haben und wir haben uns für das
technisch am einfachsten und
sinnvollsten und am schnellsten
durchführbare verfahren entschieden das
ist der grund warum es diesen konkreten
weg gehen das wird zum ersten januar
kommen nach unserer zielsetzung wir
haben das technisch mit so einer
verordnungsermächtigung verknüpft weil
wir ja bei digitalisierung auch in der
hand von anderen sind nicht von gott
aber von ingenieuren und insofern dass
wir sehen wie es klappt aber ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass wir das
hinbekommen werden und das wäre ein
großer schritt
übrigens ist dieser schritt auch nicht
nur gut in dieser konkreten krisenhaften
situationen sondern es ist auch die
richtige
minute um das zu machen denn wenn die
umsätze generell gering
sind sind die liquiditäts nachteile die
der staat durch die einführung dieses
system hat überschaubarer als in
boomzeiten das kann man sich ja
vorstellen
das ganze kostet uns am ende kein geld
aber in dem jahr wo wir es machen kommt
es schon auf milliarden heraus und
deshalb ist das genau der richtige
zeitpunkt dafür
wir haben in dem programm in dem
konjunkturprogramm festgelegt dass wir
uns dafür einsetzen eine europäische
initiative für den austausch älterer lkw
durch neuere zu voranzubringen
das ist sowieso notwendig weil als
nationales programm hat das ganze
überhaupt keinen sinn
es geht bei der industrie um eine
industrie die in deutschland in
frankreich und skandinavien in italien
beheimatet ist die aber ihre fahrzeuge
in ganz europa verkauft und wer jetzt
angesichts dieser nachfragenden branche
in der logistik glaubt dass er mit einem
nationalen programmen etwas machen kann
der kommt nicht weit
darum haben wir die vorschläge die mir
zum beispiel der konzernbetriebsrat von
mrm gemacht hat aufgegriffen und diese
europäische initiative zum gegenstand
des konjunkturprogramms gemacht und es
wird der dann jetzt unsere aufgabe sein
wenn wir über die frage was machen wir
mit den 500 milliarden des recovery fans
in europa schon richtig sein dass wir
solche themen bit auf der rechnung haben
da geht es dann um die lkw da geht es
wahrscheinlich auch um die frage wie wir
verhindern dass flugzeuge mit ihren und
heute nicht mehr notwendigen co2
emissionen unser klima schädigen und das
alles kann man aber nur angesichts der
größeren räume von logistikprozessen nur
europaweit bewirken
übrigen wollte ich nur darauf hinweisen
dass wir neben den steuerlichen
maßnahmen im übrigen auch umfassend
mittel bereitgestellt haben für
nachhaltige mobilität das bezieht sich
insbesondere auch auf dem schiff aus
bezieht sich auf flugzeugbau ist bezieht
sich auf öffentliche personennahverkehr
und damit machen wir deutlich dass wir
den das missing link sozusagen damit
definieren zwischen dem was an
kurzfristig wirksamen maßnahmen
notwendig ist das soll auch dazu
beitragen dass wir das schaffen
aber auch das was wir brauchen damit wir
langfristig die wettbewerbsfähigkeit
erhalten und trotzdem die klimaziele
erreichen können als nächstes laura
weber von n tv anane des von bloomberg
die drogenbeauftragte der
bundesregierung daniela ludwig hat an
die koalition appelliert tabak und
alkohol von der vorübergehende senkung
der mehrwertsteuer auszunehmen
grund dafür ist dass eine senkung ja die
bemühungen der trugen politik
konterkarieren würde sind ausdauer oder
solche ausnahmen von der
mehrwertsteuersenkung denn geplant
wir haben jetzt mehr ein
konjunkturprogramm gemacht wo wir keine
solchen sonderregelung deswegen und
gemacht haben und weil man sich ja jetzt
nicht mit einem falschen federn
schmücken sollte ich sagen es gibt für
die tabakprodukte alle ausnahmeregelung
aber auf wunsch auch der beteiligten
industrie weil das umpacken aller
zigarettenpackungen wäre ein vorgang der
wäre wohl im dezember noch nicht
abgeschlossen also insofern ist da aus
anderen motiven vielleicht das richtige
passiert dann allerdings und danach der
kollege heller
der stolz ich wollte auch nochmal zu dem
sie den 500 milliarden paket fragen was
sie eben erwähnt hatten also auf
europäischer ebene da sind ja diese
schulform jetzt noch so das größte
hindernis und die hätten gerne rabatte
sehen sie da eine möglichkeit dass man
den rabatte gewährt und so deren
zustimmung zu diesem paket meinen sie
dass es der richtige weg
und herr altmaier es gibt ja den usa
eine gesetzesinitiative die in die
sanktionen zu der vorsieht gegen
betreiber von nord stream aber auch
behörden und möglicherweise sogar
befreundete regierung die mit dem
projekt befasst sind
wie bewerten sie diesen vorgang hat ja
insofern eine neue qualität als eben
nicht nur mehr unternehmen betroffen
werden von diesen sanktionen die
initiative die frankreich und
deutschland ergriffen haben um dafür zu
sorgen dass europa eine gemeinsame
antwort auf die gegenwärtige pandemie
und ihre wirtschaftlichen folgen findet
hat glaube ich dazu beigetragen dass
alle den pfad erkennen auf dem ein
konsens in europa und der 27
mitgliedstaaten möglich ist jetzt geht
es darum das zu konkretisieren und zu
diskutieren
aus meiner sicht gilt da was auch hier
in deutschland gilt ein
konjunkturprogramm ist ein
konjunkturprogramm also nicht ein
vorwand für geld das man sich per kredit
aufnimmt und dann die nächsten 20 jahre
ausgibt sondern ein anlass geld
aufzunehmen um es in diesem jahr und dem
nächsten jahr
und was europa betrifft vielleicht eher
in der zeit 21 und 22 auszugeben wenn
das danach folgt erfolgt ist die krise
vorbei um recovery hat erstmal was damit
zu tun dass wir allen helfen aus der
konjunkturellen delle herauszukommen
übrigens eine debatte die ich von allen
regierungen in europa gehört habe und
deshalb glaube ich wird man dort noch
eine fokussierung von dem müssen in den
politischen vorschlägen die wir bisher
kennen und das zweite ist es gibt einen
zusammenhang zwischen dem
recovery fand dem wiederaufbauprogramm
für europa und den mehrjährigen
finanzrahmen für die haushalte der
europäischen union ab 2021 für die dann
folgenden sieben jahre und aus meiner
sicht ist der nicht nur naheliegend
sondern vielleicht auch die basis für
eine konsensfindung
ich will nur ausdrücklich dazu sagen
dass ich mir schon vorstellen dass wir
uns nicht zu lange mit der frage
aufhalten werden wie wir einen konsens
finden aber dass es auch nicht ein
moment von zwei tagen sein wird sondern
das wird uns schon noch im sommer ein
bisschen beschäftigen aber wenn der
sommer zu ende ist sollten wir auch
durch sein jedenfalls diese hoffnung
möglich loswerden
ja und was die usa und das thema in nord
stream angeht ich glaube es macht wenig
sinn zu spekulieren über maßnahmen die
möglicherweise beschlossen werden aber
die bundesregierung ist schon seit
langem der auffassung dass sanktionen
mit extra territorialer wirkung zum
völkerrecht im streit stehen und dass
sie auch keinen beitrag dazu leisten die
internationale zusammenarbeit voran zu
bringen
an dieser position hat sich nichts
geändert gernot heller und danach geht
es an von der fc auch zwei fragen einmal
wir werden mit der pandemie weiterhin
leben müssen mit dem virus weiterhin
leben müssen haben sie gesagt wann ist
denn der zeitpunkt an dem für sie sich
die entscheidung stellt ob das programm
das sie jetzt vorstellen so richtig
angeschlagen hat das heißt wann ist für
sie der punkt zu sagen wir müssen noch
mal nachlegen oder das programm hat
verfangen dass wir müssen nicht mehr
nachlegen das ist die eine frage und die
zweite frage kurz auf die auf die reform
der kfz besteuerung
nachgefragt kommt da unter dem strich
für den bund für den staat mehr raus
oder ist das eine aufkommensneutrale
sache und die haben sie mal
durchgerechnet ein durchschnittsbürger
mit einem durchschnitts auto steht der
sich mit der neuen form der kfz-steuer
besser oder schlechter ich und ich sage
mal wir halten nichts von debatten über
ein weiteres konjunkturprogramm das ist
das konjunkturprogramm und mehr will ich
dazu gar nicht sagen
wir haben sehr genau überlegt was wir
machen wir haben das sehr intensiv
diskutiert nicht nur wenn der 21 stunden
im koalitionsausschuss sondern war der
sehr sehr sorgfältigen vorbereitung und
dabei haben wir viele viel sachverstand
einbezogen es mit verbänden unterhalten
mit gewerkschaften unterhalten mit
unternehmen mit arbeitnehmern
unterhalten wir haben uns unterhalten
mit den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern die uns
volkswirtschaftliche ratschläge zu geben
haben und das ist schon sehr genau was
wir uns dort überlegt haben willst noch
mal sagen da dass er jetzt ein
allgemeines wissen geworden ist worüber
ich sehr glücklich bin ein
konjunkturprogramm muss die schönen 4gs
widerspiegeln time design das ist jetzt
genau an diesem tag ist es richtig es
muss target sein das ist das was wir
genau gemacht haben das ja ab teil
unserer gesprächsrunde hier
es muss temporary sein das heißt
befristet und so haben das auch gemacht
und es muss natürlich auch transformers
sein darauf achten dass wir die
zukunftsfragen nicht vergessen
digitalisierung klimawandel
wasserstoffwirtschaft und ausbau der
ganztagsangebote den krippen kitas und
schulen das sind viele viele dinge die
dafür von ganz großer bedeutung sind und
das haben wir mit erwogen
was die frage betrifft kfz besteuerung
wird es eine leichte vermehrung unserer
einnahmen geben und dann geht es schnell
zurück denn wenn diese steuer keine
wirkung hat dann da und der technische
fortschritt auch nicht stattfindet dann
ist das alles überflüssig aber wenn sie
dieses ziel erreicht das sie erreichen
sollen werden die einnahmen eher nach
unten gehen also wir rechnen im verlaufe
des kommenden jahrzehnts er mit am ende
sinkenden kfz steuereinnahmen wegen der
reduzierten co2 emissionen von
fahrzeugen und das wird natürlich eine
großartige sache wir haben
elektromobilität jetzt auf das ganze
jahrzehnt erstreckt dass die steuerfrei
genutzt werden kann
wir haben schon vor langer zeit die
dienstwagenbesteuerung die hier für den
neuwagenkauf von größter bedeutung ist
über 50 prozent von 60 prozent der
neuwagen sind dienstwagen die erworben
werden haben wir mit den maßnahmen für
elektrische fahrzeuge und
elektrifizierte fahrzeuge verstärkt
jetzt kommt noch die mehrwertsteuer
senkung dazu die viele natürlich auch
überlegt und lässt ob sie hat sich eine
emission gemindert das fahrzeug kaufen
sollen und die industrie ist ja auch
längst dabei
denn wenn unsere sehr leistungsfähigen
hochtechnologie konzerne mit ihren
tollen großartigen
industriearbeitsplätzen in der
automobilindustrie die zukunft sichern
dann machen sie das ja weil sie all die
europäischen regeln über abgasemissionen
auch einhalten werden und die 95 gramm
spielen wir ja zum beispiel eine rolle
was diese perspektive betrifft wenn das
alles schaffen wird der staat erhebliche
einnahmeverluste haben in dem fall sage
ich ist das auch gut so ja nur ganz kurz
das konjunkturprogramm ist das
konjunkturprogramm
da sind wir uns in der tat einig
wir müssen es auf die straße und in die
haushalte bringen auch da sind wir uns
einig und der auftrag ist heller dass
wir trotz einer eher auf längere sicht
veränderten normalität einen aufschwung
ermöglichen
das ist kein hexenwerk dazu wird es
gehören dass sich die unternehmen die
konsumenten auch zum teil umstellen und
anpassen auf an neue regeln und
veränderte bedingungen
ich will aber nur darauf hinweisen dass
zum beispiel auch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung natürlich auch für
kühlschränke und autos und andere
produkte gelten die man online kauft bei
den unternehmen und bei den
einzelhändlern dass es möglich ist durch
kreative entbürokratisierung maßnahmen
auch im privatwirtschaftlichen bereich
erfolge zu erzielen und das wir nicht
dauernd auch über immer neue ausgaben
reden sollten ergibt sich auch daraus
dass wir verantwortlich mit der
finanziellen belastung auch für künftige
generationen umgehen werden aber
natürlich verbietet uns niemand dass wir
dann im laufe der nächsten monate auch
verstärkt darüber nachdenken wie man
ohne neue mehrausgaben etwa im bereich
von rechtlichen gesetzlichen
erleichterungen planungs
beschleunigungen dazu beitragen kann das
vorhandene finanzielle mittel dann auch
tatsächlich zielführend eingesetzt
werden das hat noch zwei wortmeldungen
die shazam von der ft und danach peter
titel von der bild als letztes ich habe
eine frage zu den aussichten für die
deutsche wirtschaft also im april gibt
es die gab es diesen historischen
einbruch um 18 prozent in der
industriellen produktion
aber sehen sie an den hoffnungsschimmer
also dass deutschland vielleicht
schneller aus der rezession als ihre
nachbarn herauskommen könnte und auch
als die usa und alle haben noch eine
zweite frage also wahr was halten sie
von der behauptung dass deutschlands
wirtschaft langfristig in wirklichkeit
wesentlich verletzlicher ist als andere
da sie vom export und aus
internationalen handel ab
insbesondere von der nachfrage in china
die sich nicht so schnell erholen wird
danke also ich sehe ein
hoffnungsschimmer dass die wirtschaft
sich erholen wird hierzulande und auch
anderswo
ich glaube dass wir mit dem was wir
jetzt gemacht haben dafür sorgen dass
sich insgesamt die wirtschaftliche
konjunkturelle situation aufhält also da
bleibt nichts nicht beim schimmer da
scheint die ganze sonne jedenfalls ist
das die perspektive die wir verfolgen
und das ist nicht nur deshalb richtig
weil wir ja jetzt mit zwei paketen
jeweils schnell und gross gehandelt
haben
im ersten zur stabilisierung der
volkswirtschaft im zusammenhang mit dem
ausbruch der pandemie dem zweiten
konjunkturprogramm am ende des lot downs
damit die wirtschaft wieder wächst und
damit ja auch ein zeichen gesetzt haben
für die entwicklung in europa insgesamt
viele handeln ja ähnlich sondern auch
deshalb weil wir nicht nationalistisch
verblendet sind sondern eine ganz klare
erkenntnis haben die uns die ganze zeit
begleitet das wird nur gelingen wenn es
vor allem in europa aber auch
international erfolgreich gelingt eine
wirtschaftliche bessere entwicklung zu
erreichen und deshalb ist es zwar
europäische gesinnung und europäische
begeisterung die uns dazu gebracht hat
jetzt so massive pakete auf den weg zu
bringen zweimal 500 milliarden zusammen
eine billion für europa sondern auch
natürlich das verständnis dass bei einer
längst zusammengewachsenen europäischen
volkswirtschaft es überhaupt nicht
gelingen kann als ein land alleine
dauerhaft sich wirtschaftlich zu erholen
das muss man schon miteinander gelingen
und die tatsache dass es uns nützt was
wir gut finden ist dann ja auch das
beste motiv für mutiges und couragiertes
handeln und das werde ich dazu sagen für
das abschütteln von
vorurteilen und handelsbarrieren die uns
in der vergangenheit vielleicht daran
gehindert haben das jeweils richtige zu
tun
das machen wir ja nicht nur im hinblick
auf die europäische union
sie finden in dem konjunkturprogramm
auch drei milliarden die wir für
weltweite unterstützungsmaßnahmen zur
bekämpfung der pandemie daran gebaut
haben das wird noch ergänzt durch viele
entscheidungen die wir so unter dem
radar längst getroffen haben um zum
beispiel den internationalen
währungsfonds die weltbank der
internationale hilfsorganisationen zu
unterstützen
die weltgesundheitsorganisation zu
unterstützen das heißt wir haben den
blick darauf dass niemand so vermessen
sein sollte dass er alleine in der welt
zurecht kommt ohne die anderen mit dem
blick zu haben
die deutsche volkswirtschaft ist sehr
leistungsfähig weil sie letztendlich
sich sehr schnell technologisch und
unternehmerisch angepasst hat an das was
den wohlstand unserer welt heute
ausmacht und auch in zukunft ausmachen
wird das will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen nämlich die globalisierung dass
wir das sage ich jetzt auch als
sozialdemokrat natürlich was tun müssen
für eine faire globalisierung die
entwicklungsperspektiven für alle mit
guter mit guten verlauf beinhaltet das
ist klar aber dass die globalisierung
einen unglaublichen wohlstands
fortschritt mit sich gebracht hat
milliarden menschen auf der welt in die
mittelschicht hinein wachsen lassen das
ist doch unübersehbar und es gibt jetzt
darum dafür zu sorgen dass das auch
jeder perspektive richtig ist vieler
länder die wirtschaftlich nicht so stark
sind aber natürlich auch in dem sinne
dass hoffnung auch für die sehr starken
wirtschaftlich leistungsfähigen länder
existiert und deshalb bin ich fest davon
überzeugt dass deutschland ein
hoffnungslauf sein kann wie ich das
einmal genannt habe wenn es sicherstellt
dass alle in unserem land aber zu gut
zurechtkommen wenn wir so weltweit
vernetzt sind aber dass wir nicht
zurückgehen sollten
in denen wir mit ganz kleinen
größenordnung und geringen
technologischen fortschritt letztendlich
weniger wohlstand
er hat noch hier stimmen wir überein die
geschichte der volkswirtschaft hat
eigentlich seit dem phänomenalen
aufstieg der phönizier als handels volk
vor über zweieinhalbtausend jahren immer
und immer wieder bewiesen und gezeigt
dass exportorientierte vernetzte
interaktive volkswirtschaften wesentlich
erfolgreicher wesentlich wachstumsstärke
und auch wesentlich wohlhabender sind
als autarke gemeinschaften die sich von
der außenwelt abschotten
das gilt auch jetzt allerdings hat
natürlich die aktuelle krise gezeigt
dass es auch verletzlichkeiten gibt im
hinblick auf lieferketten die einseitig
ausgerichtet sind im hinblick auf
abhängigkeiten aus einzelnen regionen
und deshalb werden wir in der deutschen
präsidentschaft der eu auch darüber
reden wie wir solche internationalen
lieferketten resilient da das heißt
widerstandsfähiger machen können zum
beispiel indem wir sie diversifizieren
aber es geht ausdrücklich nicht darum
die globalisierung zurückzudrehen zu
stoppen oder zu verlangsamen weil wir
glauben dass wir damit unserem eigenen
land erscheinen würden wenn sie nach den
volkswirtschaftlichen daten fragen und
dem silberstreif am horizont
dann ist es natürlich in der tat so dass
wir ja im april und im mai zwei ähnlich
schlechte und schwierige monate hatten
das heißt die enttäuschenden zahlen für
april die ja nicht wirklich eine
überraschung waren werden sich wenn die
zahlen für den mai in einigen wochen
vorliegen wahrscheinlich nicht
durchgreifend davon unterscheiden
trotzdem ist der optimismus oder der
silberstreif der kollege scholz und ich
sehen darauf begründet dass sich zum
einen in der stimmung schon ein
deutlicher trend ins positive abzeichnet
das hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass wir
als land insgesamt erfolgreich
und angemessen auf diese herausforderung
reagiert haben und zweitens hat es etwas
damit zu tun dass wir sehen können dass
sich unternehmen mit ihren investitions
vorbereitungen und mit ihren vorhaben
auf die zweite jahreshälfte ausrichten
dann wird auch das konjunkturprogramm
seine wirkung erst richtig entfalten
können und das macht uns optimistisch
dass wir ab der zweiten jahreshälfte
dann auch bessere zahlen haben werden so
hätte zum letzten zwei fragen einer
erstmal ein herr scholz herr scholz
können sie in drei kurzen sätze sagen
wer den familien bonus bekommt und wie
kommt er auf das konto wer hat was davon
wer nichts und dann eine frage an beide
wie viel von dem konjunkturprogramm
hätte man sich sparen können wenn wir
vor der pandemie wie seit jahren ja
gefordert einen vorrat in den ländern
und beim bund an tauglichen masken
persönlicher schutzausrüstung und
desinfektionsmitteln gehabt hätten es
kriegen
es wird für alle kinder dieses
kindergeld gezahlt alle familien
profitieren davon
und das gilt auch weil wir bestimmte
regeln wieder in kraft gesetzt haben die
wir schon einmal als wir ein kinderbonus
hatten in deutschland bereits geschaffen
hatten
er hat zum beispiel auf
grundsicherungsleistungen auf
sozialleistungen angewiesen ist bekommt
diesen kinderbonus für seine kinder auch
und es wird nicht verrechnet und es ist
gleichzeitig gewährleistet dass das
nicht dazu führt dass jemand der viel
geld verdient ein paar hunderttausend
euro jetzt mehr geld kriegt schlichtweg
deshalb weil man das dann nicht braucht
sondern die freibeträge mit denen das
kindergeld immer gegengerechnet wird und
die ja normalerweise dazu führen dass
diejenigen die viel geld verdient etwas
mehr nach haben was viel kritisiert wird
die sind nicht verändert worden sodass
praktisch dass der kinderbonus jetzt für
alle kinder wirkt in familien die ganz
wenig verdienen die auf öffentliche
leistungen angewiesen sind genauso wie
an geringverdiener normalverdiener in
deutschland nur diejenigen die sehr viel
haben die werden mit dem freibetrag ganz
gut ausgestattet ist weiter
zurechtkommen und die zweite frage
das hätten wir man so haben sollen das
hätte uns allerdings nicht die
volkswirtschaftliche konsequenzen
erspart die damit verbunden sind
das hätte uns aber geholfen bei der
bekämpfung der pandemie und deshalb darf
das auch nie wieder geschehen das muss
die lehre aus dieser situation sein kann
wundervoll mit dieser harmonischen
schlussbemerkung bedanke ich mich für
ihre disziplinen ihr kommen ihr
interesse und auch bald